[Música]
y vamos a hablar entonces de el
metaverso empresas como facebook google
y microsoft están decidiendo apostar por
un nuevo concepto del mundo virtual
donde nos podemos conectar usando
dispositivos que nos van a permitir
hacernos pensar que estamos dentro de
este mundo interactuando con todos sus
elementos hay tres aspectos claves de
este meta verso primero la presencia
también la temporalidad y luego la
estandarización la presencia es la
sensación de estar realmente en este
espacio virtual con otros amigos
virtuales también la intemporalidad que
significa poder viajar sin problemas
entre espacios virtuales con los mismos
activos como avatares y elementos
digitales y también está la
estandarización que es lo que permite
también la intemporalidad de estas
plataformas y los servicios en todo este
mundo del metaverso estamos a propósito
de que ya la empresa en facebook cambió
su nombre a metta vamos a hablar
entonces con nuestra segunda
el día para que agradezco por estar con
nosotros ella es linda patiño analista
digital y escritora de la tecnología
difícil linda de entender este metaverso
le preguntó en pocas palabras en
palabras sencillas que es el metaverso
es un concepto bastante
curioso incluso hemos llegado a pensar
que es nuevo como bien lo decías porque
ha sido muy noticias últimamente pero en
realidad es un concepto que nació en el
año 92 en un libro de ficción y se
trataba precisamente de un espacio
alternativo donde la gente podía recrear
un personaje recrear cosas de su entorno
y adaptarlas a su propio criterio e
interactuar con otros el metaverso es
básicamente un espacio digital en el que
yo creo un personaje para interactuar
con otras personas y tengo unas
capacidades de acción bajo esa idea ya
existen metaversos por ejemplo como
league of legends world of warcraft el
mismo forma donde yo tengo unos avatares
y los puedo personalizar y tengo la
posibilidad de interactuar con otros en
tiempo real y de viajar de un escenario
a otro un poco lo que plantea facebook
con sus anuncios y también que están
trabajando otras grandes tecnológicas es
llevar esa idea de interacción de
metaverso a una internet más sensorial
en la inteligencia de la inteligencia
artificial de la realidad aumentada y de
la realidad virtual y es allí donde
esperamos estar dentro de 20 años en una
internet experimental ahora linda porque
surge esta necesidad de crear un
metaverso teniendo un mundo real cuál es
la finalidad para que lo están creando y
que buscan las personas de un metaversos
de la misma manera en que existe una
comunidad de consumo de lujo por ejemplo
o de la misma forma en la que nosotros
queremos comer postres a pesar de que
nutricionalmente no nos hacen ningún
bien y no tienen ningún tipo de aporte
calórico real para nosotros en el día a
día los seres humanos estamos agregando
capas de complejidad en nuestra forma de
interactuar entre sí estamos
experimentando con las herramientas que
tenemos al lado yo creo que esto es un
desafío tecnológico es cumplir una serie
de promesas que están en la ciencia
ficción pero también es una exploración
sobre cuáles son los medios de
comunicación humanos como esa
naturalidad de expresión la podemos
llevar hacia otros lados y francamente
es increíble yo poder ver cosas que
antes no veía a través de unas gafas a
través de unos lentes de contacto hace
que las posibilidades sean más grandes
imagina poder enseñarle a una persona
cómo hacer una cirugía a corazón abierto
con un corazón que no tiene que tocar
sino que lo pueden ver 200 personas sin
importar en donde están ubicadas
pueden interactuar con él no increíble
obviamente cómo suena todo eso pero
también linda le quiere preguntar qué
tanto nos puede aislar esto más allá de
yo creo que cada día estamos más
aislados no la pandemia de kobe 19
también nos ha hecho estar como más en
casa no querer socializar con tantas
personas está esta nueva generación
digamos también prefiere quedarse en
casa viendo netflix que compartir con
los amigos que una familia entonces esto
sería como otra manera de aislarnos un
poco del contacto físico porque digamos
que si vamos a estar conectados en éste
metaverso pero físicamente los humanos
necesitamos interactuar entonces hay una
dicotomía y que como podemos resolver
eso sería también uno de los problemas
de este metal eso linda
por supuesto que yo comparto la
preocupación de que hayan personas que
prefieran quedarse en el metaverso a
estar en los espacios reales pero si lo
pensamos un poquito más esa sensación de
soledad esa digamos aislamiento de una
persona puede ocurrir hoy en día con los
videojuegos con los cómics con un montón
de elementos incluso antes de que
llegaran las redes sociales es difícil
predecir cómo va a ser el comportamiento
de las personas con el metaverso y si
esto va a ser una cuestión más y va a
seguir siendo unos casos determinados de
personas que buscan refugio en gatos
plantas juegos o en el metaverso para
aislarse de cosas que no le gustan
dentro de esa realidad que de pronto va
a hacer los abruman
yo creo que no podemos descartar el tema
de que si vamos a necesitar mucha
alfabetización digital vamos a necesitar
también las posibilidades de que la
gente pueda interactuar de formas
diversas pero creo que echarle la culpa
a tal vez o una tecnología de algo que
ha venido pasando socialmente entre
nosotros incluso con la ausencia de lass
sociales sería un poco injusto sobre
todo porque creo yo que la virtualidad
nos permite son opciones dentro de esas
opciones por supuesto la naturaleza
humana cuando abrimos canales de
comunicación distintos puede dejar ver
sus peores facetas pero también sus
mejores facetas ahora linda hablemos de
el metaverso en el trabajo el futuro del
mundo laboral reuniones virtuales todos
reunidos en el metaverso en un mismo
espacio con nuestros avatares
como lo ve
lo veo lejos todavía yo creo que nos
falta una buena cantidad de tecnología
para llegar a que esta experiencia de
trabajo remoto y experimental
experiencial en internet sea una
realidad y pongamos como ejemplo cuánto
tiempo hemos tardado en la adopción del
teletrabajo a través de google teams de
google forms de google teams de todo el
tipo de
suites de trabajos que ya tenemos hoy en
día y que con la pandemia se catalizar
en un momento antes de la pandemia
estábamos hablando de una adopción
alrededor de un 50 por ciento del
teletrabajo en las empresas en américa
latina' puede que con la pandemia
hayamos subido a un 60 a un 70 incluso a
un 80 después de la pandemia se espera
que esto vuelva a bajar porque hay
personas que siguen prefiriendo modelos
más híbridos más presenciales entonces
yo creo que esta opción va a tomar
tiempo abre opciones para que yo en vez
de estar trabajando en un archivo y
tener que llevar una usb o tener que
descargar un o algo tenga un espacio
físico que todos mis compañeros podamos
ver y de alguna manera colaborar allí
asíncrona y sincrónicamente pero pues
todavía estamos en pasitos de bebé se
diría